[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the ben
shapiro show got a lot coming up for you
this hour a little bit later on in the
hour we'll be joined by senator joni
ernst from iowa she retained her seat a
very
very very big race because republicans
need to maintain a majority
in the senate but we begin with all of
your vote count updates
so here's where things stand right now
joe biden has taken a narrow lead in
pennsylvania
absentee ballots were being tabulated
this morning
that lead is likely to expand over the
course of the day president trump has
filed some lawsuits regarding
ballots coming in after the election
date and whether those ought to be
counted or not it is unclear how many of
those ballots there actually are
meanwhile in arizona
biden's lead has dropped down to 1.6
points about 50 000 votes
as more late absentee mail ballots are
counted
late mail voting in arizona has broken
pretty heavily for trump
so arizona is probably going to continue
to tighten all right it is it is unclear
whether trump overtakes biden in arizona
meanwhile in georgia
that is edging toward biden according to
the new york times biden has edged ahead
by just over 1 000 votes
there's not much counting left to do
there's a scattering of absentee votes
across the state there will be a recount
there's an automatic recount provision
in georgia law beneath 0.5
in nevada biden has expanded his lead to
about a percentage point or 9 thousand
votes
his lead is probably going to grow
further today because there are 190 000
votes left to be counted 90
of them are in clark county which is a
democratic stronghold so
needless to say the president is behind
the eight ball in terms of the actual
vote count
president trump is protesting that the
election has been
tampered with that voter fraud and voter
irregularity are the problem he has
launched a series of lawsuits on this
basis
uh in philadelphia he launched a lawsuit
claiming that the
philadelphia officials were not allowing
republican
to republican poll watchers to actually
view what was going on
that lawsuit was successful in
injunction was granted nearly
immediately
the trump campaign also put forward a
lawsuit to try and
bar the counting of ballots that either
arrived after election day or that were
unclearly marked before election day
so we'll see how that proceeds all of
this of course has led the the left to
absolutely
lose its mind so the left is
preemptively celebrating of course
and the left has decided the election is
over this has led to idiocies like david
corn of the nation
tweeting out when trump was elected i
decided i'd only wear black ties
it was a personal and private act of
mourning i didn't say anything about it
and almost no one noticed over these
past
four years today and then he tweeted out
a photo of himself
wearing a uh wearing a silver tie wow
the heroism just just wow
so impressive meanwhile folks on the
left
celebrating and enjoying themselves but
not as much as you might think because
as we'll discuss in just a little while
it turns out that
the left really doesn't have all that
much to celebrate even if joe biden were
to win a
narrow victory over donald trump in a
extraordinarily
heavily voted year they're not gonna
have any power against the republican
senate they're not gonna have any power
come 2022 when the republicans take the
house
and in 2024 they would have an 82 year
old joe biden going up against
somebody in the republican party who
could theoretically be trump again
right or kamala harris who is the least
likable candidate to walk the earth
since hillary clinton
okay with all that said it is not yet
over the trump
team has put out a statement saying that
uh
the preliminary declaration that the
election is over is indeed
preliminary they put out a statement
suggesting quote the election is not
over the false projection of joe biden
as the winner is based on results in
four states that are far from final
georgia is headed for a recount or we
are confident we will find ballots and
properly harvested
and where president trump will
ultimately prevail there are many
irregularities in pennsylvania including
having election officials prevent our
volunteer legal observers
from having meaningful access to vote
counting locations we prevailed in court
on our challenge but were deprived of
valuable time and denied the
transparency we are entitled to under
state law
in nevada there appear to be thousands
of individuals who improperly cast mail
ballots finally the president is on
course to win arizona outright despite
the irresponsible and erroneous calling
of the state for biden by fox news and
the associated press
biden is relying on these states for his
phony claim on the white house but once
the election is final
president trump will be re-elected for
what it is worth the president has also
said
that obviously he's going to obey the
law as they move forward that doesn't
mean that he's going to concede the
election under any circumstances it does
mean
that he's going to wait for all of this
he's gonna wait for all of this
to play out uh and he's not gonna hole
up in the white house
and uh do blow and fire machine guns
through the door like al pacino at the
end of scarface that's not a thing
that's going to happen but again
this thing is not yet over and listening
to democrats complain about this not
being over listening to democrats saying
today ought to be our celebration day
why can't it be a week from now why
can't it be
two weeks from now why is it we want to
celebrate now it's our right to party
i'm just gonna point out that democrats
have undermined legitimate elections for
all of my lifetime
al gore was on msnbc yesterday declaring
that he defended the election system
okay that is not true here is al gore
very al gore
defending america from our election
systems
from global warming here's al gore
but the most important principle that i
defended 20 years ago
that joe biden and many others are
defending
tonight is let's count every
legally cast vote and obey the will
of the american people okay sorry to
break it to al gore but no he was not a
defender of america's
voters al gore tried to disenfranchise
military ballot
al gore attempted to have ballots read
by looking to voters intent which is
insane that's how you ended up with the
pregnant chad controversy
not like chad who works for us being
pregnant like the pregnant chad
controversy that's impossible
but like like the the pregnant chad
controversy where people tried to punch
their ballot and it didn't
wholly work and so you'd have someone
look into their heart to determine who
they voted for
even so gore ended up losing that
election hillary clinton just last week
suggested that the election was stolen
from her so
amid all the hue and cry about how trump
is so terrible for saying the election
is stolen
then i don't like when anybody says the
election is stolen when the election
there's not proof yet that the election
was stolen right and we're still waiting
for all the lawsuits to go forward we're
still waiting
for all of the for all of the
information to be tabulated
it's okay to be suspicious this is why
we have a legal process and we should go
through the legal process
but democrats don't have a leg to stand
on when they suggest that
they stand for election integrity here
was hillary clinton last week suggesting
that
her election was stolen there's an air
of illegitimacy
that surrounds trump's presidency and
that just infuriates them
it makes them crazy and
that's a big piece of it so they have to
keep striking out at me
because why you why well because i was
the candidate that
they basically stole an election from i
was the candidate who won
you know nearly three million more votes
they stole an election you see it's it's
okay when hillary clinton says it that's
totally fine
and it's okay when we spend four years
hunting for
russians under our bed because it was
probably their fault that hillary
clinton lost but if donald trump says i
want to go through the legal process
and i think i won with all the legal
votes and the illegal votes that are
coming in
the those are the ones deciding the
election then we all have to set our
hair on fire
do i like those kind of statements no do
i think that that's hair on fire stuff
not after the democrats keep claiming
that georgia
georgia's stacey abrams is actually the
governor over there she lost by 50 000
votes
50 000. now democrats right now are
complaining that trump
is filing lawsuits in wisconsin he lost
wisconsin by 20 000. stacey abrams lost
by 50.
like two and a half times the margin and
yet stacey abrams is a hero of the
resistance
so spare me spare me the crocodile tears
just a little bit
so here was president trump's statement
last night there was some stuff
to like some stuff to hate as always
with president trump here was president
trump last night correctly saying
that the polls totally jacked him that
the polls were
maybe designed in order to keep people
from giving money to the campaigns
particularly in swing states
he said you know you kept predicting
this big blue wave it wasn't there's a
big red wave
as everybody saw we won by historic
numbers
and the pollsters got it knowingly wrong
they got it knowingly wrong
we had polls that were so ridiculous and
everybody knew it at the time there was
no blue wave that they predicted
they thought there was going to be a big
blue wave that was false that was done
for
suppression reasons but instead there
was a big
red wave and it's been properly
acknowledged
actually by the media okay and uh he's
right about that he's also correct that
this was a great year for republican
women 13 of whom were added to congress
haven't seen any girl power stories from
the media yet because they're so
objective right
here's president trump correctly calling
out the media this was
also the year of the republican woman
more republican women were elected to
congress than
ever before that's a great achievement
okay that is true okay then we got to
the controversial portion this is where
trump says that they are trying to steal
the election now
it may very well be that there are
people in philadelphia who've engaged in
election fraud in fact there was a story
back in may of a federal prosecution of
a person who's stuffing ballot boxes
that was like 24 ballots here 40 ballots
there 100 ballots here
could there be voter fraud in
philadelphia sure why not
is it going to amount to tens of
thousands of votes pretty unlikely
also the idea that in every one of these
states including like georgia for
example voter fraud
is to blame i mean the georgia secretary
of state's a republican the governor is
a republican
in arizona the governor's a republican
and by the way you're not seeing a lot
of claims of voter fraud
in arizona from the trump campaign
presumably because the late mail-ins are
coming in
on trump's side nonetheless here's
president trump saying that they are
trying to steal the election
there's tremendous litigation going on
and this is a case where they're trying
to steal an election
they're trying to rig an election and we
can't let that happen detroit and
philadelphia known as two of the most
corrupt political places
anywhere in our country easily
cannot be responsible for engineering
the outcome of
a presidential race it's a very
important presidential race
okay so yeah are they trying to steal
you'd have to define the they you'd have
to provide the evidence of the stealing
and that's what lawsuits are for
we have a process for this everybody
stop panicking over the fact that trump
says stuff he says stuff we all know it
okay the stuff he says is not always
stuff that i like if this is not baked
into the kick by now i really don't know
what is plus the vote has already taken
place
right nobody else is voting it's not
like the stuff he says right now is
gonna shift the vote it's over
the vote already happened and president
trump continued along these lines he
said they never believed they could win
this honestly
democrat officials never believed they
could win this election honestly
i really believe that that's why they
did the mail-in ballots where there's
tremendous
corruption and fraud going on that's why
they
mailed out tens of millions of
unsolicited ballots without any
verification measures whatsoever
and i've told everybody that uh these
things would happen
because i've seen it happen okay so
again asking questions about this sort
of stuff is not forbidden and this is
why we have a legal process and we'll
have to let that
play out where trump of course goes too
far as he says if you count all the
legal votes i win if you count the
illegal votes they can steal the
election
and that's moving beyond the evidence to
conjecture but
that's trump and again for the one
thousandth time there's a process for
this
democrats who've spent the last several
years claiming that russians stole the
election
or that facebook stole the election or
that hillary clinton is the actual
president or that governor
stacey abrams of georgia is in fact the
governor of georgia
uh they have no i don't want to hear
from them honestly here's trump
if you count the legal votes i easily
win
if you count the illegal votes they can
try to
steal the election from us if you count
the votes that came in late
we're looking at them very strongly but
a lot of votes came in late
alrighty so president trump concluded by
saying that they would take all legal
action
which is of course where this is always
going to go right i mean it's going to
go to court
it'll be adjudicated they'll have to
show evidence of the voter fraud
if there is not enough evidence of voter
fraud to overturn the results of the
election
then this thing is is over i mean that's
that's the way that it's going to work
right we do have processes in this
country in this country i'm a fan of
evidence as you know
just as when democrats claim that every
time a white cop shoots a black person
it is racism and then i say let's look
at the evidence
if we're going to claim voter fraud and
voter irregularity every one of those
cases should be fully investigated to
the fullest extent of the law
and then we should determine whether
there is in fact enough evidence to talk
about widespread
voter fraud resulting in actual changes
to the election outcome here's president
trump
saying that he's going to take legal
action we want an honest election
we want an honest count and we want
honest people working
back there because it's a very important
job so that's the way
this country is going to win that's the
way the united states will win
and we think we will win the election
very easily we think there's going to be
a lot of litigation because we have so
much evidence so much proof
and it's going to end up perhaps at the
highest court in the land
we'll see but we think there'll be a lot
of litigation because we can't have
an election stolen by it like this
okay there will be litigation and then
we'll have an answer
meanwhile our esteemed journalistic
community has deemed it completely off
limits for trump to even discuss voter
fraud and voter irregularity even though
again
al gore did this in 2000. john kerry did
some of this in 2004 right the die bold
machines were going to ask john kerry
from office we got this from hillary
clinton last time around
but when trump does it it's super duper
duper much worse than when democrats do
it here is jim acosta jim acosta inc
a preemptive celebration from jim acosta
who loves himself like no journalist
except for jeffrey toobin
the president is watching the lights go
out on his presidency right now
that is what we're witnessing in real
time as these votes are being tabulated
and joe biden is catching up in
pennsylvania
and in georgia the the presidency of
donald j
trump is vanishing before our eyes
okay so these journalists they can't
by the way this has some down ballot
effects if you think that what happened
the other night is not a referendum on
the failures of the media you're dead
wrong the media claimed that joe biden
was going to wamp trump and not only
that
republicans were going to lose all
across the land joe biden was going to
enter
office with a with a wind at his back
with a with a democratic congress with a
democratic
senate majority a major democratic
senate majority
that ain't gonna happen uh those media
they've been lying to you they've been
shifting
all information through their prism of
bias and that is perfectly obvious
anderson cooper right here's another
esteemed journalist another member of
our journalistic cadre
trashing trump and calling him pathetic
and fat which of course is is just what
a journalist would do right
it's sad and it is truly pathetic and of
course it is dangerous and of course it
will
go to courts but you'll notice the
president did not have any evidence
that is the president of the united
states that is the most powerful person
in the world
and we see him like an obese turtle on
his back
flailing in the hot sun realizing his
time is over
but he just hasn't accepted it and he
wants to take everybody down with him
including this country so there it is
your journalistic community i can't
imagine why people showed up in droves
because they don't like the media
the failures of the media here are
endemic if trump is going to talk about
a stolen election seriously in the
future
i think he's on much more solid ground
talking about a stolen election
on the basis of the media having
completely shifted the nature of the
race
being awful being liars that is
that is unimpeachable i mean that is the
reality that doesn't count as stealing
in the sense that
like votes got shifted secretly in the
middle of the night
but if you're talking about the fairness
of elections if you're talking about the
overall
justice of a media that lies to you
that's a bigger endemic issue than
the number of people who are supposedly
stuffing ballot boxes in the end because
that's gonna outlast any election
so the media are relieved because they
think that trump lost and the adults are
back in charge right except for one
problem the adults are not back in
charge there are no adults okay let's be
real about this
andrew bates the biden campaign
spokesperson he put out a statement
quote
as we said on july 19th the american
people will decide this election
and the united states government is
perfectly capable of escorting
trespassers out of the white house
yeah you guys were you were so worried
about trump being a vulgar boar and all
of this
or alternatively you just didn't like
him because he's a republican and that
made you mad
and all of your protestations about his
character it was a bunch of crap
but that's what all this is about isn't
it you see it from members of the media
all the time
which is that if you are on the right
you're a bad person and they can't let
go of this narrative they ca
they don't see how damaging it is by the
way it is very damaging to them
if they just stop insulting voters for
half a second they might have more of a
mandate but they can't stop insulting
voters because they actually believe
that if you don't vote with them you're
a bad human being
we need to be lectured by our moral
bettors
are the same people lecturing us about
trump's manners who then proceed to have
no manners of their own
it's it's pretty impressive stuff you
get this from the media all the time joy
reid
saying that the race shows that racism
and anti-blackness are still dominant in
the united states
even though we intellectually understand
what america is at its base right
that there is a great amount of racism
anti-blackness
anti-wokeness this idea that political
correctness is some sort of
scheme to destroy white america right
like we know what this country is
but you still part of you i think part
of your your heart says you know what
maybe the country is gonna
pay pay off all of this pain the
children were stolen
with the repudiation and as the night
wore on and you
and i realized and it sunk in okay
that's not happening we are still who
we thought you know unfortunately we are
still racist we are still terrible
america's still racist and
keep saying it over and over and over
until you think it's true at which point
you guys will be
in the deep electoral minority i also
need more lectures from our late night
house so
our late night host did some of this
over the over the course of the last
couple nights america's terrible
you guys you're bad america should be
lamented
keep doing this really here's the thing
that people are missing about the trump
phenomenon
in the end when all said and done about
president trump there's a lot of attempt
to intellectualize trump and policy
but the reality is that trump connected
with people because they hate hate
hate coastal elitists who tell them that
they are better than they are
that's really what trump is about trump
did not look down on people in middle
america and
laugh at them or scorn them that's not
what trump is about trump actually hates
the same comedians you hate remember
those very very popular comics
those people have maybe what 5 million
viewers a night
there's 330 million people in this
country 160 million people just voted
here's a jimmy kimmel on our late-night
comedians informing you that you're a
bad person
he is a liar and a cheat who wants them
to stop
counting thousands of legitimate votes
and almost half of us are apparently
okay with that
be careful america if you let trump do
this
then voting could soon become one of
those things that people do to
feel better but doesn't actually do
anything as usual
the state that got us into this mess was
florida every four years democrats hope
they'll take it
but once again last night florida was
called for donald trump
florida's officially america's cheating
boyfriend
why do we always think we can change him
yeah just keep pissing on the voters you
need guys just keep doing it we're
joined on the line by senator joni ernst
the pollster suggested
that she was in a dog fight with her
opponent theresa greenfield it turns out
that that dog fight was not much of a
dog fight in the end senator joni ernst
prevails it is a huge win because
it probably assures a republican
majority in the senate senator ernst
thanks so much for joining us on
congratulations
oh my gosh it's so great to be to be
done
and of course thanks to all of my
supporters who came out
in force yep we put this one to bed
and you put it to bed pretty easily as
it turns out in the final analysis
what do you think the pollsters
completely missed because they missed
iowa by by everything except for
the seltzer pole which of course got it
right as they do pretty much every time
right and i think they miss so much um
about our rural voters they
tend to to lean a little more republican
of course and they turn out in force and
so
you know the pollsters they've gotten
wrong in so many of the races this year
and again just just thankful to you know
have the support of the the people of
iowa i didn't pay attention to the polls
because i
i didn't feel that the polls were right
i felt a different
level of energy and enthusiasm and of
course
you know the polls weren't right about
president trump either they had him neck
and neck with joe biden
and he he put it to bed easily as well
okay so let's talk for a second about
what you think the message of the
election is we'll get to the
presidential race in just a second but
what do you think the message of the
election is i think that the message of
the election is that the democrats
tacked
so far to the left in the obvious
opinion that trump was just so unpopular
they could be able to to do that and
pick up seats instead they lose house
seats all over the country
they don't take any of the state
legislatures in a redistricting year
it's basically a disaster for them their
coalition seems to be
coming apart at the seams uh they might
be able to mask that
if joe biden ends up winning the
election after all of the legal tallies
and everything
but it's not going to be much of a mass
that coalition looks like it's
fragmenting
right and ben i think you're absolutely
correct and that
the left has gone so far to the left
that it has disenfranchised so many of
their voters you know you look across
the midwest and in particular here in
iowa our democratic voters are much more
to the middle you know we do have our
french groups
but they want to see people working
together to get things done
they don't want to see things like the
green new deal they don't want to see
things like packing
the supreme court um so you know the
left has overplayed their hand
and i hope that they learn from that
lesson
so uh when you look at the democratic
lefty do you really think that they're
going to learn that lesson i
have a feeling they won't it seems like
they're sort of held hostage by a wild
leftist base
you saw this i don't know if you were
aware of this senator ernst but there
was this this
leaked phone call the dccc phone call
last night in which
basically all hell broke loose abigail
spanberger who's running in a purple
district and
may have barely pulled out a race
against nick frieda she went off on the
squad she said that we can't say
socialism anymore we have to stop
talking about defunding the police
meanwhile you had rashida talib saying
you want to leave the priorities of
black people behind and you and you only
care about rural white people
that that coalition does not look like
it is it is something that can last
even the next couple of years no
and i look at aoc and the demand she's
making and of course
chuck schumer cowering to aoc
and pushing all of the senate democrats
further
to the left and you know we saw that
with
even my opponent while she tried to play
off as a moderate i mean she was backed
by aoc
she was backed by a number of these far
leftist liberal
organizations and iowans saw that and
they said
no thank you no way no how. um
so i don't know if they're going to
learn their lesson but i certainly hope
they do
senator joni ernst i want to ask you
about control of the the senate so
obviously your race was not just
important because we need more
republican senators from iowa but
obviously we need more republican
senators generally
it was slated that republicans had maybe
a 25 shot of keeping the senate uh this
was maybe my my only good election call
of the last several years i thought that
republicans would maintain the senate i
thought that you would win your race i
thought susan collins was going to win
her race
now it looks like republicans are in
fact going to retain the senate and even
if joe biden were to be
made president of the united states
you'll be facing up to a senate majority
led by republicans how important is that
it is extremely important and you know
just very telling i ran to the grocery
store last night and
ran into a number of friends there and
and they were asking me about the
presidential they're very worried about
the outcome of the presidential
and the only uh saving grace they said
is that you've kept your seat and the
senate
should stay a republican majority and it
is the last line of defense when it
comes to the crazy radical ideas
that are trying to be pushed by people
like aoc in the squad
pushed by chuck schumer in order to you
know appease those on the far
far left um so again things like you
know the green new deal
medicare for all socialized medicine
all of those things are packing the
court that was a big concern here
uh all of those things can be kept in
check
with a republican majority in the senate
it's like that last line of sanity
you know should we have a president joe
biden
we're speaking with senator joni ernst
ernest one of the i think there are a
lot of marks of optimism for republicans
in this election again regardless of the
presidential outcome one of the marks of
optimism
is i think the the growth of
republicanism uh among
non-white voters uh president trump won
a large number of latino voters
particularly he did well with hispanics
in in florida
in in texas and and he did an outside
share of of uh
republican he got an outside share of
republican votes uh among black
americans
as well uh this looks like a much more
durable coalition going forward it looks
as though the the woke notion the
demographics are destiny which is shared
by the the racist alt-right actually
they're all of the same piece which is
that you can judge people simply by the
color of their skin and not by anything
else
that is breaking down if people are
treated as individuals it looks as
though you could easily see a situation
in which republicans
continue to garner larger shares of the
hispanic and black vote and
simultaneously bring back in
women who may not have voted for
president trump in 2016 or 2020 moving
forward
yes i think that is so important and i
think through the movements we've seen
over the course of the last year those
that really
want to see solutions put into place
um you know i've had a number of
meetings with members of the
african-american community here
in iowa and you know there's some
brilliant young leaders out there and
they see their path forward as
economic prosperity and how do you get
there you get there by following the
policies of president donald j
trump so as we're lifting people out of
poverty you know that's not a thing
based on the color of your skin
it applies to you know all demographics
out there
but again there's just so many people
now that are recognizing
you know we can do better for our
communities we need to work together we
need economic prosperity
and you know i i've had such great
conversations with people
and you know i had a member of the
african-american community a dear friend
of mine that sat with me all night
um as we were watching the election
results coming in
and we had this conversation and he said
i'm a democrat and i told him you know
i don't think you are a democrat
so but uh you know but he was there to
support
me and so it's it's kind of an awakening
that we
are seeing in certain communities um
certainly
in some of the hispanic communities with
some of the issues that are important to
them
um of course it's again coming back to
economic prosperity
you know it it lifts a lot of folks up
and
provides them a brighter future just
being a senator joni ernst let's turn to
the presidential race for just a moment
obviously this thing
is still hotly fraught you're seeing
networks today calling the election for
joe biden because
biden apparently has pulled ahead in the
vote count in pennsylvania georgia
remains extraordinarily tight arizona
remains extraordinarily tight nevada
remains extraordinarily tight the
president is claiming
that the only way that he could win is
through voter irregularity um yeah i'm
skeptical of the claim that's the only
way
that he could lose uh but certainly i
think all of these claims should be
sussed out i mean this is why we have a
legal process
uh and it seems to me that the american
people should be patient enough for
another week to figure out uh who
exactly won and make sure that all the
legal ballots get counted
absolutely ben i'm 100 in agreement
because i
i did serve as a county auditor here in
iowa
also as an elections commissioner and so
every state has their own process and
system
but uh what we do know is that any
ballots that were cast
legally should be counted any ballots
that were not cast
legally then they should not be counted
and the likely outcome
is that this will have to go through the
courts
possibly um and if so then
we will see we'll see that process play
out but
again we do need to be patient and we
need to
make sure that that we are um adhering
to the laws that are
available in each of our states and
hopefully the president will have a good
outcome
um but again if ballots were cast
legally you know by qualified voters
those ballots should be counted well
senator joni ernst again congratulations
on a major win has serious
ramifications not just for your state
but for the nation as a whole
it's a big win it's an important win and
uh thank you for running such an
excellent race
oh you betcha ben and again thanks to
all my supporters i really do appreciate
it
well all the talk about the presidential
election is obscuring a big problem for
democrats their coalition is utterly
unworkable nancy pelosi
refuses to step down refuses refuses
she's again launching a bid to keep the
gavel for another
two years she's led the caucus since
2003.
she's actually been a terrible speaker
of the house a legit awful speaker of
the house
she has now presided over the democrats
getting their butts kicked in 2010
and then the democrats getting their
butts kicked again in 2014
and then again the democrats getting
their butts kicked in 2020. so she's
been here forever just like every other
democratic leader
the geriatric ward of the democratic
party continues to maintain
control and be louded by the media for
their genius
but the fact is that they are falling
apart a little bit pelosi alluded in her
letter to her fellow democrats
to the tensions within the party noting
the quote diverse viewpoints of our
democratic caucus
and the urgency of the challenges ahead
she said our caucus is blessed with many
diverse and entrepreneurial perspectives
okay that is one way of putting it that
your coalition is utterly unworkable
so in what had to be the most
entertaining development of yesterday
evening
there is a democratic house caucus call
absolute mess
absolute mess erica warner washington
post congressional reporter
was being leaked the contents of this
call by other democrats who are on the
call because
understand that for the democrats and
the media they're the same democrats
just see the media as their house organ
the outlet for their communication
strategy so here is what erica warner
reported
abigail spanberger who is a democratic
congresswoman from virginia she
barely barely barely returned receipt by
like 5 000 votes out of 450 000 cast
spanberger on the democratic caucus call
quote we lost races we shouldn't have
lost
defund police almost cost me my race
because of an attack ad don't say
socialism ever again
need to get back to basics in
parentheses is yelling
which is a great way to start by the way
that's right right socialism
that word socialism may have cost the
democrats florida because it turns out
you know who doesn't like socialism
anyone who has ever lived in a socialist
country
heavily latino areas hate socialism
defund police you know i don't like that
nearly anybody white people don't like
it black people don't like it latino
people don't like it
get rid of the cops and guess what the
people who thrive are criminals
if we run this race again we'll get
effing torn apart in 2022 spanberger
says
then pelosi came back on and said she
disagrees they won the house and the
presidency
so you went from democrats were supposed
to pick up five to ten seats two
democrats
lost 10 to 15 seats and pelosi says
that's a victory
why because here's the problem nancy
pelosi
it's too late it's too late for nancy
pelosi the squad is in the bloodstream
as i said earlier on the program the the
democratic party is basically the
elderly
the aging hollywood star attempting to
energize himself by finding some 20 year
old aspiring star
and literally taking his blood out of
his body and then injecting it himself
by the way this is a weird thing
hollywood stars do
i'm not kidding this is an actual thing
okay so that is what
nancy pelosi is she was living off the
energy of the democratic socialist the
squad
woo the ilhan omars and the and the
ayanna presleys and the rashida talibs
and the honorable congresswoman
alexander ocasio-cortez d-twitch
and they were living off that and then
it turns out that um there's only one
problem which is there's leukemia in
that bloodstream
it kills the host so pelosi says they
have a mandate
also earlier in the call debbie mccassil
powell who lost her race
was crying she mentioned how people
can't pronounce her name and said stop
being negative on twitter
hakeem jefferies who is pelosi's second
in command and widely perceived to be
her heir
comes back on to tell people to stop
leaking and that reporters aren't your
friends
meanwhile representative jayapal was
telling jeffreys to find the leakers it
just keeps going
as pascarelle now calls out schumer
pelosi's done an amazing job but where's
schumer in all this says pelosi has one
hand tied behind her back
then rashida talib chimed in and said
before we make painful statements we
need to wait and see how the numbers
come down
feels like i'm being asked to be quiet
we need to appeal to certain people and
that not
that's not right what rashida talib
actually said according to the
washington post by the way
is that it seems like the democrats care
more about rural white voters than black
voters
good luck with this coalition gang good
luck good
effing luck the end is in sight for the
democratic caucus call that started more
than two hours ago said erica warner
wrapping up
jeffrey said seven to eight members in
queue and then we'll wrap up
one more random detail earl blumenhower
said marijuana was the big winner of the
election so that's big the democrats
really focusing in on the things that
people deeply deeply care about
so this broke out into the open in a
variety of ways over the last over the
last couple of days
perhaps most amusingly claire mccaskill
was on msnbc and she points out the
obvious which is democrats ignored the
issues and that's why they lost
the republican party i think very uh
adroitly
adopted cultural issues is part of their
main theme
whether you're talking guns or issues
surrounding the right to abortion in
this country
or things like gay marriage and the
right for transsexuals and
and other people who we as a party have
tried to
quote unquote look after and make sure
that they're treated fairly
as we you know circle those issues we
left some voters behind and republicans
dove in with a vengeance okay claire
mccaskill was right about this
they left all these voters behind it
turns out there are a bunch of socially
conservative democratic voters
black white and hispanic who don't like
all the culture war crap
and democrats decide to focus in on it
they don't like the word socialism they
don't like to fund the police
so naturally this prompted soul
searching from the honorable
congresswoman alexander ocasio-cortez i
call her that because i've been informed
by her that it is sexist to call her aoc
despite the fact
that her twitter handle is aoc so the
honorable
estimable congresswoman alexander
ocasio-cortez de twitch
she tweeted out why do we listen to
people who lost elections as if they are
experts in winning elections
mccaskill tried her approach she ran as
a caravan hysteria dem
and lost while grassroots organizers won
progressive measures in missouri
her language here shows how she took her
base for granted
so um i'm just going to uh point out
here that
aoc sorry representative ocasio-cortez
degree new deal d brooklyn
right she says that she knows how to win
in missouri oh man nancy pelosi have
fun with this gang seriously have fun
with these folks because they are
a par-tay you have an utterly unwieldy
coalition you got a bunch of socialists
who refuse to stop saying socialism even
when it damages the party in other areas
of the country
you got a bunch of people who think the
transgender locker rooms are top
priority
even while you got voters who are dying
of heroin overdoses
you got a bunch of folks who think that
black lives matter and defund the police
are a good idea
hey just enjoy yourselves gang it's
gonna be a party it's gonna be a party
no wonder the democrats are falling
apart it turns out the intersectional
coalition of barack obama only works
when barack obama
is in charge to pretend that it works
even then it didn't work so well
but certainly it's not working now okay
i wish to conclude the week with a
little bit of uplift so every week i do
a little bit
of a bible talk at the very end of the
friday show so this week
the jews read a portion of genesis that
surrounds
sodom and gomorrah and this is one of
the most fascinating portions of the
bible
because this is the first time that you
really see human beings negotiating with
god
god says he's going to destroy sodom and
gomorrah and then abraham
asks god will you spare it if we can
find 50 righteous people and god says
yes
he says 40 righteous people god says yes
he says 30 righteous people
he says yes 20 yes 10 yes okay
and then that's the end of the
conversation and now
what most people read that is god then
says to abraham i can't find 10 i'm
destroying it
that's not actually what happens that's
not actually what happens the next thing
that happens in the bible
is the move to sodom and gomorrah right
two angels come to sodom
in the evening and lot is sitting in the
gate of sodom and lote
saw and arose and he welcomes them to
his house
and here are the people who are in
motels so he's now got two angels right
so it's two
those two angels plus load he has two
daughters
right so that means five he's got his
wife that's six and he's got his two
sons in law that's eight
so all that abraham needs in order to
preserve sodom and gomorrah
is two more people to stand up two more
people
in the entire city to stand up for
righteousness and the entire city gets
spared even though it's filled with
tons and tons of bad people instead
as the bible says everybody shows up to
try and uh
to try and abuse the visitors it says in
the bible that the entire town
shows up everyone the men the women the
children
young and old the entire populace so
here's the reality
all it takes to stand up to the bad guys
is just a couple of people that's it
just not one two because you need some
solidarity
it's hard to be the lone voice but all
it takes is a few righteous people
standing up to sin
and you can spare the entire city
because you can fight back from that
base so remember that going into the
weekend no matter how this election ends
the the fight has only just begun for
the soul of the country and for the
future of the country and all it takes
is a little bit of solidarity and a
solid core group to fight back against
that and he can still save the city
that's the real message of what abraham
talks about with god there were just two
people away in sodom and gomorrah from
saving the city
the two people didn't materialize the
city gets destroyed
so find a friend team up and then try
and save the country
i think we can all do that together
alrighty we'll be back here next week
with all of the recaps of the news i'm
sure it is going to be
a hotly fought weekend so try to rest up
by the time we
see you on monday we'll know a lot more
about where things stand i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
you